it just looks a lot like a deep-fried
chicken on a stick
hey I'm Tom I'm from England I'm Julie
I'm from Arcadia California and I am
Mexican hi I'm Chloe and I am British
and I'm Oscar and I'm from Mexico and
we're gonna be doing a snack swap I
don't know a lot about British snacks I
actually don't have any experience with
British snacks
but I wasn't London for the first time
this year you might have had someone not
realise if you've been there if you went
to visit you might have had some stuff
well I know nothing about Mexican snacks
at all I've heard in California for
almost five years that's how you ought
to know a little bit yeah I've been to
Mexico a few times but I don't know what
they're like classic snacks are like
I've tried a bunch of stuff but I
wouldn't be able to pick out what is
like something anything spicy
okay so we have Pocky this is like
staple Mexican second I have like
probably got one Mexican it doesn't like
this I'm more of a hot cheeto guy is it
cheesy I love these these are amazing
how would you pronounce that word
Worchester yeah we basically elide
everything and call it whip stir more
stir what's the sauce oyster oyster
sauce and they're very like traditional
British flavor and then Walker's is our
lathe that grasps not chips thank you
I'm sure I like yours better than Mike's
oh my goodness
it looks like lava that's actually oh
not bad the lime makes it less hot than
I expected but then the aftertaste is
quite up okay yeah it's our soul eaters
means that were insulted by lightless
flights like a lot of heat on my mouth
it's good right
it is actually pretty nice yeah I mean
I'm on fire but it's nice good yeah yeah
I approve all I need is like some
Chilean lime oh yeah I can get on this
train I'm trying to remember what they
make what's the sauce out of oh it's
like it's rancid chutney I think that's
essentially what what's the sauce is
does it mean the same word yeah in
America yeah so when it's pasta - expiry
date oh it's it's what's this oh cool so
yeah these are good these are some good
chance yeah yeah I mean it's good I'm
sorry they win please win hands down I
would go attacking objectively nicer
taste
look us here we have Lucas chamoy it's
really just like a powdery substance say
you lick your finger and you stick it in
there and just look about that's kind of
like it tastes like salty spicy lemon
flavor one of the things that we do with
like we have food I'm kind of good fruit
and just like tippet yeah that sounds
lovely
it sounds like sherbert except it's not
sweet yeah
you've had that ice cream like it's
basically just sugar flavored sugar and
you sort of you can set it from straws
or okay it might be some in fact inside
these flying discs if I remember
correctly what is this I used to see
them all the time in like candy shops
where you have like like a pick-and-mix
me but to pick out one oh here just like
a candy store yeah and you just like put
them all in a bag whatever you wanted
and so these were always like the
classic life yeah oh there's stuff
inside yeah you know what it reminds me
on that first I'm not Catholic I've been
to Catholic Church cuz like communion by
the way the body of Christ this is like
I'm about to be blessed but like double
blessed because there's like a sugar
explosion yeah it's like once you get to
like the candy it's actually really good
if it's like flour but it's marketed not
as as communion not as the body of
Christ but as flying discs but like
alien Christ yes exactly and I'm on
board with that and Boop yeah it looks
horrible just but just put a little oh
it smells even worse just put a little
bit in the palm of your hand and then
like a look at all okay I understand
that's good it is great though it's like
yeah it's definitely not just sweet I
don't like these many flavors yeah after
you put it in it's like been there a
little while the heat starts to happen
yeah oh oh oh yeah oh that's like sugary
yeah there is some definitely some sweet
in there but also an awful lot of salt
yeah
I would go with Mexico on this one yeah
I think I agree that is from what I
remember the color weird and like weird
I don't yeah it's yeah this yeah this is
I like a little different flavor that's
good it's not like my favorite of all
Mexican candies and snacks and I can see
why but I felt like I was in a holier
place so I'm gonna go with era sugar
communion wafers I think I'm gonna also
have to go with the alien cries this
Valletta the mango yeah it's just a
mango flavored pop and then around it it
has chili a mine
you're in for a treat I'm not even gonna
tell you what it tastes like mango
mm-hmm okay
these are wine gums these do very
classically British wine gums
they're like gummy candies basically all
different flavors is your like gummy
bears on steroids
they're like bigger mm-hmm they're not
as sweet as I thought philippi okay
we're kind of like it's just like
gummies but like like harder thicker
consistency I really get stuck in your
teeth I'm used to like sugar sugar yeah
when these are like not that sugar what
did you eat a whole bag of them but
they're good
oh boy okay Sigma cool it looks kind of
hairy it just looks a lot like a deep
fry the chicken on a stick like the
smell of that is so unique like what is
not know so much it's not almost like
straw mixed with like spice bite it oh
really I like to play hard yeah oh God
oh I like how you just that is not nice
I'm sorry and they can taste all of it
this is just like licking the chili off
yeah cuz the outside too sour for me
like on its own but once you get in the
middle yeah I thought I get a lot more
mango than didn't solve the mangoes in
the center alright so I just got a stick
with the salt for a really long time
before I get the speaking I do keep
getting like a renewing style of it well
I'm telling you we put lime and chili on
everything oh we just keep making gonna
get closer to the mango her good I feel
like I want the flavors to be more
together because I'm keep tasting and
reciprocally
make my mouth water I'm actually
well now I'm stuck with it okay okay
yeah like high candy the way a popsicle
I suppose are supposed to taste rather
than all yea really unique I remember
just as a child like licking it and then
like having another one it just kind of
like tears up your tongue a little bit
it's it's um toughening kids up
basically like this is what horrible
it's like a allegory for life
I'm glad I persevered yes definitely
Mexico wins agree more sugar I'm just
gonna have to go with the pineapple
mango because that's just like one of my
favorites as a kid I had such a horrible
experience so it's got to be the wine
gums
I mean just ice to heat it up yeah so
here we have sponge marshmallow cookies
with like some sprinkled coconut and
like a little fruit taste with it all
right
have you ever heard of this thing before
Oh like it's taken a cab okay this is a
snack that tastes a lot better than the
name would suggest it's spotted dick
which everyone loves that name it is the
stupidest exactly I don't know why it's
called that the raisins do look like
spots dick I assume it's just you know
short for Richard right now big big
again and you normally have this with
hot custard but in order for you to
appreciate it in its purest form we've
got it on its own I want to have a very
pure experience with any kind of spotted
dick that I'm involved with thank you
very much oh yeah it looks pretty too I
love coconut and I love marshmallow I
love cookie bits oh it's going
everywhere it smells like old fruit may
be rancid fruit okay I don't know with
the English hat white English have a
thing for rented fruit but we don't do
that that's not how we roll and make oh
yeah it's really good oh and I like the
fact it has a little jam blob in the
middle I always picked the jam out
because I don't yeah it does actually
taste very nice I like the texture
thanks dub - no definitely
so step two you're gonna have to try
this I'm ready for the D that one's very
spongy
it's actually called a pudding which
peoples is just also a generic term for
dessert oh but pudding is also a very
specific thing specifically this then a
spongy so - I feel like I have to learn
an entirely new English language not
drive No okay good Stefan's not drive
this is the first time I'm gonna say
like a canned cake
it's actually good quite a good one
isn't it when do you usually eat it warm
like this yeah you have to eat it you
don't want to coast but it did no one
likes a cold spotted dick like Fred beam
it out of a can like it's not dry it
happens has some really good flavor it
also smells like carrot cake person yeah
it does but I don't taste any character
I'm like I don't take any carrot in here
you know what it's not bad it could use
a little what was it that I needed
custard custard yes
is that like it makes it moister it's
like like a pudding
oh well custard is okay what's big and
yet what's yellow and highly dangerous
[Music]
shark infested custard the spotted dick
is good okay I love spotted dick with
custard so have that had custard that
would win but it does it since it
doesn't I think I'm gonna go with this
purely because it's not completely
correct I'll go with that - just because
I'm missing the experience
Oh dick I'm gonna go with the spotted
dick it's a little bit like like
flavored with a real food kind of Li
yeah and this is good but it's like
artificial flavored
right I'm gonna have to agree with you
on this I'd much prefer the spotted dick
yeah it's like a very nice for cake I
like but like you'll have so many
flavors I like that your guys's stuff
also has flavors cuz I tried to sign
some other countries that are kind of
flavorless but you like you guys have a
flavor which is good yeah we're kind of
known to not have really I'm like
everybody tasted had like a good balance
of different flavors yeah
tasting different things especially most
shippers I'm glad that you know the
rumors weren't true about British snacks
you know there wasn't as much of a kick
obviously like I feel like Mexican
candies really give you more of a punch
sometimes yesterday sometimes I would
say that punch is worth it and other
times I would say no thank you I feel
like I had to learn another English
language yes and your terminology was
probably more charming than mine fun
sounding words like sponge instead of
frightening words like rancid or spotted
dick what about it I am delighted to
have been introduced to a different way
of eating you know what diplomats need
to do this I feel like this is really
building bridges it certainly is
[Music]